However, it's not all doom and gloom.
In 1987, over 30 countries signed the Montreal Protocol,...
...in which the signatories agreed to cut CFC use by 50 percent by the year 2000.
This protocol was further extended two years later,...
...when over 80 countries agreed to stop using CFCs completely by the year 2000.
Also, in 1991, a fund was set up to help developing countries...
...change over to non-CFC technologies, and it has met with some success.
Hopefully, new technologies will continue to provide safer alternatives...
...to CFCs, HCFCs and other gases that harm the atmosphere.
One current example is the increase in use of coolants in air conditioning units...
...which break down into relatively harmless compounds...
...before they can reach the stratosphere.
However, there is still some use of ozone-depleting gases...
...such as methyl bromide in some pesticides,...
...and some countries who haven't signed the Montreal Protocol are still using CFCs.
Because of this, and because of the long lifespan of the CFCs...
...that are already in the stratosphere,...
...it's estimated that it will take several lifetimes for the ozone layer to recover.